I'm told that you guys didn't have a
really a full script early on you just
did when you guys start shooting the gym
yeah I mean it I mean Justin wrote what
we call a scrip mint but essentially
it's it's a script that's 50 pages so
it's basically it's like a traditional
script if you were to take out the
dialogue so everything is I mean if you
see the film obviously it's not it's
very structured it's not sort of like oh
let's try this out you know it was like
very detailed Lee written and then and
then while we are on set Justin would
script pages for the next day but we
liked we liked the idea of going into it
with a lot of improv just because we
really worked on these characters and
made sure that we kind of understood
them in their history and we felt like
you know having improv bringing the sort
of natural very organic kind of
relationship banter worked really well
and then and then once Justin kind of
got a sense of what where we were all
going with the dialogue he would script
stuff for the next day so originally it
was just gonna be the script meant and
the whole movie was going to be
completely improvised and we didn't
realize like obviously if we knew that I
was going to be scripting pages on set I
would have there's no reason to do that
on said I would have done it before
while we were prepping but and it ended
up because of rehearsals and because of
all the prep work that we did and
talking about the story and talk about
the characters it actually stayed pretty
close to what those last 30 pages were
and then yeah unset it became it became
apparent that they were so good they
knew these characters so well they were
so great at improving that I think what
I if anything when I brought to it on
set was just pacing because they're like
Charlie said it so and tricular plotted
and there are so many scenes that it
they didn't have the freedom if there
were less scenes to be like oh we could
riff for 30 minutes and find the scene
like if it's like if the scenes meant to
be a two-minute scene we're wasting time
if we're spending 40 minutes riffing so
where I think I was useful was even if
they didn't use a dialogue from a pacing
standpoint it was sort of like okay
this seen as two pages long and this is
our starting off point and the first
four or five lines we kind of have room
to play between these lines but by line
six I need to say this bit of
information to pivot into the next scene
so the next scene makes sense so it was
a lot of like sort of puzzle connecting
I did really respond to as a director I
really cared about stories with
characters and that we're sort of
character driven and and I really do
care about performance and I'm sort of
that over you know I justins much more
about the plotting and kind of structure
of everything and I'm sort of like I
want to focus on performance and so
going into this I think this film really
lent itself to having both which was
great and then so in terms of our actors
we developed the story with mark so we
had mark you know an idea of mark before
we went into it and then he mentioned
that Elisabeth Moss wanted to do this
sort of intimate kind of films that he
had done before and so that's right when
I saw top of the lake which I thought
was unbelievable and I was like yeah how
would she ever want to do this and it
was all done through like text messaging
mark was like check out the script and
he like sent it through his phone and it
was like very sort of rinky-dink you
know just like our little bubble there
was no agents involved or anything like
that and she read it and loved it and
and we did we just a lot of character
work beforehand and kind of really
created their history in their past and
some of it came through in the film but
most of it was just so that they
understood their characters and kind of
had that going into it because a lot of
this is sort of the baggage that comes
with a history of your relationship and
so we really wanted to create that and
and and i think you know we were able to
do that i didn't i didn't know that my
scripts are not meant to be read over
the phone i'm just kidding the types of
movies that we sort of that we sort of
respond to that we try to make that
we're you know we're developing another
script now that will hopefully be our
next movie it's basically taking what
could conceivably be the studio big high
concept idea but telling it in a very
different way than you're accustomed to
telling it and I think
what that is is finding the honesty of
it and keeping it about people and how
they react to something not the big
version because with the premise like
this there's a there's a temptation to
not necessarily make it broad but like
make it bigger and he was very very from
like page one Charlie's imprint on it
was it's kind of feel real it's got to
be grounded and what that ended up doing
from it for me personally from a story
perspective is as long as that stuff is
grounded and honest and real you could
take the concept as far as you want if
that's you take it further than what you
even where you even thought you could
take it and if it was bigger and broad
from a character standpoint the concept
would even would start to feel really
really ridiculous so and I think to just
the idea of like how do you take a
traditional story that people can
connect to and and you know make
relationships with their own life and
their own kind of baggage and how do you
tell it in a different way you know and
we looked at you know something like
eternal sunshine which is essentially
you know if you if you break it down
it's about a guy trying to get over girl
it's like kind of the most simple story
and then they take you on this kind of
wild ride and because of that I think we
connect to that film more so than we
would have it was just a kind of
traditional narrative and so I think
going into this we were thinking you
know we have the restrictions of budget
and you know we're basically shooting in
one location but we're like how do we
tell a story that people can connect to
but also you know have it be something
that people talk about as you know this
is a totally different thing that I've
seen before